what's up everyone it's time for the NHL Allstar
mock draft we're going to be showing you a little
preview of how things might go down at NHL
All-Star Thursday in Toronto when the actual
players choose their team so let's kick it off no
further waiting starting off with the best team
I'm just a tad bit biased the Hughes Brothers
as you've never seen us before I'm your deao
host Anna daa and I'm here with NHL fantasy's
Pete Jensen how you feeling Pete what's going
on Anna yeah happy to rep the NHL fantasy on Ice
team also the Hughes f and really excited about
all the festivities going down in Toronto yeah
we're taking over the NHL just a little bit but
there's still one player who's at the top probably
the best player in the entire world Conor McDavid
also known as nhl.com David satriano how are you
Dave I'm very good I like that I'm referred to as
the best player when I'm the only one with the
person Cory Schneider here my teammate played
in the NHL so hopefully uh he's got some insight
on some of these guys yeah we've got NHL networks
Corey Schneider here and Corey you're probably the
only person here who's actually qualified to do
this do you have any tips for us pretending to be
NHL players for the first time well the good news
is that they're all Allstar so you can't really
go wrong but I think David and I are going to be
able to get it right so that's the only issue we
have oo some fighting words out here early now the
yellow team two good Canadian boys led by nhl.com
Bill price how you feeling Bill I'm feeling great
ready to go who you playing I am kale ma my
partner here is Liam Cav up in Nova Scotia
he's one of the NHL power players and he of course
being from Nova Scotia is Nathan McKinnon love to
hear it how you doing Liam are you excited yeah
I'm doing great uh as a Nova Scotia boy myself I
feel like I'm somewhat qualified to be Nathan
McKinnon uh maybe not as much as Corey is to
pick the players as far as that's concerned but uh
we're gonna give it my best so love to hear it and
wrapping it all up last but certainly not least
our hometown host Toronto's very own The Blue Team
of Austin Matthews Morgan Riley led by Sha or from
nhl.com Eric Marin from from nhl.com guys take it
away well I'm playing Austin Matthews and I I I
got to object a little bit already Anna I'm upset
best player in the world have you seen how many
goals I've scored this year I think you need to
reconsider I was trying to be a little bit humble
we all know it's Jack Hughes and Eric how are you
feeling right now feeling great happy to represent
Morgan Riley and uh get this thing started love to
hear it now I'm your deao host we also have a deao
commissioner which is Bill price I don't know if
this is cheating guys but Bill take it away tell
us what we're doing today well we had a lot draft
lottery at a undisclosed location in New Jersey a
couple weeks ago and the order selected was blue
first yellow second white third red fourth it is
a snake draft which means the used Brothers will
pick fourth and fifth and then we'll come back
around and Matthews and Riley will pick eighth
and Ninth and we'll go from there everybody has
one minute to make their pick and if you take that
time you'll be mocked mercilessly mer you'll be
mocked so anyway uh everyone's going to pick seven
skaters and two goalies Austin Matthews Morgan
Riley you are on the clock first of all we'd like
to thank the city of Toronto and all the fans that
are tuned in for hosting this we're not going to
do a lot of suspense we're not going to take the
whole minute we know who we're going with it's the
right pick William neander of our Toronto Maple
Leafs shocker shocker Willie Styles first off
the board moving right along yellow team you guys
are AES I'd like to thank Captain Obvious and co-
Captain Obvious for making that pick nice work
we have another obvious pick I'm going to send
it to Liam up in Nova Scotia to make the yellow
team's first pick all right so uh we are going to
take uh well we're going to put together the Tim
Horton's commercial buddies uh they're going to be
back together for the first time in a couple years
uh so with Nathan McKinnon already there we are
going to take Sid the Kid Sydney caros Hometown
reunion you can't beat it white team please give
me something that surprises me just a little bit
well Cory I think we have the first real decision
here to make um I know we discussed this long
and hard right before this draft but there's a
couple guys we could take um I'm thinking someone
in Boston there by the name of David Pak might be
good for us might be a goal score we could use I
heard he's decent I mean right-handed guy to go
with our Lefty shots I I I'm all in for that pick
as a Boston guy so hopefully my Patriots make the
same decision at three make a good pick this year
no football talk here I don't want to talk about
football right now now wrapping it all up we're
last Pete but certainly not least the Hugh maybe
bringing a little bit of drama take it away you
got to go first we'll go with another rightwing
here I think he's the best player available Nikita
kucherov the guy has been absolutely electric this
season for the Tampa Bay Lightning top three in
goals top three in points top three in shots on
goal and your NHL leader at the moment in Power
Play points yeah his numbers like kind of speak
for themselves so underrated in the heart trophy
conversation but I think we're back on the board
again since it's a snake draft and we have another
pick coming up now I chose this one because Pete's
pretending to be Quinn Hughes and he wanted to go
with the knock but we decided to find some middle
ground and we're selecting Brady kachuck so my
brother Quinn played with Brady kachuck in the
US national team development program Brady
top 15 in the NHL and hits top 10 in shots
on go this season the guy's a stud so excited
to have him on our team well moving on I think
it's uh Cory and my turn again now we have three
of the top scorers in the last five years in the
NHL so thinking we might need a goalie there's
someone out there that played on the Canucks and
also went to BC and it's not you so I think maybe
uh you think we should maybe go for go for him I
think p d was a good pick maybe going off the
board here with the goalie but you got to keep
the puck out of the net too in the All-Star game
so I feel pretty confident with the BC Vancouver
guy you know feels really comfortable for me I
like that Cory Schneider 2.0 no off no offense
to Cory but a goalie going sixth is ridiculous
anyway I'm just kidding so we're going to play a
little spoiler here we're to ruin the Maple Leafs
party we're going to take Mitch Marner with the
seventh pick to be on team yellow we have to add
a little drama to this allar game you can't have
all the leaf guys on one team so fair enough
Bill guys you're getting your teammate stolen
from you blue team is that who you were going
to take next it's not who we were going to take
whoa Mitch being left out we already have uh we
already have Willie Styles who's a Swede and as
Morgan Riley's from Vancouver we're going to go
with Elias Pon I like it he deserves to be taken
this high for sure great pick up by the blue team
got some kocks off the board got some Leafs off
the board a very Canadian Allstar indeed that's
happening in Toronto so before we continue let's
take a look at who's been selected so far for
each team the Blue Team Austin Matthews Morgan
Riley their captains added teammate William
neander and Elias petson from the Vancouver
Canucks next up we have the yellow team Nathan
McKinnon and kale marar they added Nova Scotia
boy Sydney Crosby and Toronto's Mitch Marner to
their squad the white teams up next Conor mcdavis
D Leon dry Sidle added David Pastak and the first
goalie off the board thater Demco wrapping it all
up with the red team Jack Hughes Quinn Hughes we
added Nikita kerov and Brady kachak let's move it
on Blue Team back to you guys well we're going
to keep it Swedish and we are going to add from
Nashville Philip forsberg classic Maple Leafs
adding the sweds to their roster not shocked
there yellow team who do you guys got I tell you
it's a great pick surprisingly for the blue team
that's right baby for third round I'm going to
send it up to Liam up in Nova Scotia to make the
pick hey uh we are going to take the Russian
goalie one of the best goalies I'd say the best
goalie in the league eigor shesterkin I like it
white team you guys are on the clock who do you
got uh I'm going to send it to Cory here to make
our our selection in this round yeah I think we're
going to take uh I think he's been called the
Austin Matthews of Florida and Sam Reinhardt from
the Florida Panthers yeah he's not getting enough
credit right there in the goal scoring race now
it's our turn wrapping it all up and I'm getting a
little bit of goalie fever right now Pete who are
we selecting we're going with the guy that is neck
and neck right now in terms of the favorites for
the VZ trophy at the moment in the NHL it's Connor
heluk for the surprising Winnipeg Jets and a guy
that leads the NHL and save percentage and even
strength save percentage minimum 20 games well to
hear it and I think Pete we're back on the board
right we got to deliberate who we want in this one
okay well I think we probably got to take a conu
right I do think we got to take a canak you want
to choose I'll let you choose yeah let's go with
uh JT Miller he throws the body around a little
bit High shot volume top five in the league in
scoring uh magnificent season so far and Quinn
Hughes his teammate so trusted guy right there
so we're getting the teammate connection going
to White team back to you guys uh I think we're
going to take someone that was Cory's teammate
for a little bit there and forward Matthew barzal
seems like a good pick nice what he's what he's
been doing for them over his career and you
know he can definitely add something to our
lineup so I think uh seems like a good pick for
us you need to be more confident team need to be
more confident yellow team I hope you bring a
little bit more confidence than the white team
just had well they say defense wins championships
I don't know about All-Star games but they'd win
championships so in addition to having Cal mcar
team we are going to add rosmus Dalene from the
Buffalo Sabers solid pickup solid pickup blue
team finish us off in this round well I don't
know if you've heard but Arizona has become
the state of hockey saying Austin Matthews
Austin my my hometown we're going to add to that
a little bit with my good friend from the Arizona
Coyotes Clayton Kelly sry Clayton Kelly this
little drama built up a little drama there the
suspense is killing me I was wondering who it was
going to be Clayton K so two more players added to
each of our team so let's recap it really quick
The Blue Team we've got Austin Matthews Morgan
Riley William nander Elias Pon Philip forsberg and
Clayton Keller next up on the yellow team Nathan
McKinnon kale marar selected Sydney Crosby Mitch
Marner eor shesterkin and rasm Dalene the white
team Conor McDavid and leand ridol selected David
Pastak that Demco added Sam Reinhardt and Matthew
barzel in this round and the red team of Jack and
Quinn Hughes selected Nikita COV Brady kach and
in this round added Connor huk and JT Miller blue
team back to you guys you are once again on the
clock well we're going to go to maybe one of the
most underrated goal scorers in the league just
back from injury going with Kyle Connor W I'm
a little hurt by this pick but good pick by you
guys nonetheless I don't want to talk about this
anymore yellow team you guys are up I'm gonna go
to Liam here he's been texting me he texted me
your pick and he also texted me I can't believe
how bad the blue team is so Liam take it away um
so uh we're going to Veer away from the center
and defenseman route as we already have plenty of
those we are going to take uh Carill the thrill
out of Minnesota okay I'm not loving this round
so far at all so this is not going great for the
red team but solid pick up for the yellow team I
guess white team you are next on the board please
take your time as we recalibrate our strategy well
I'm just going to say that as as Conor McDavid one
of my former Junior teammates is still left on
this draft board here so Cory and I are going to
select Alex to brat as the newest member of the
white team on in the All-Star Game I like that
that's a solid pickup a little offseason mover
there and now it's our turn guys our strategy got
a little bit hindered in this round but you know
what I think we're going to start off by picking
a division rival for Jack Hughes and that's
Sebastian AO of the Carolina Hurricanes this guy
flies under the radar all the time one of the most
consistent scorers actually over the past couple
of Seasons P yeah Sebastian AO playoffs a regular
season he's always up to the task so excited to
see what he could do in this format uh with all
the stars aligning here in Toronto yeah adding
some Metro love to this draft so far and Pete I'll
let you take it away well this is a Canucks party
so we're inviting Brock besser one of the biggest
surprising goal scorers of the season to date and
uh the Canucks at top the league standings right
now so they deserve all this respect here yeah
top 10 in the league in goals and someone who I
know is a big fan of Brock besser is the person
who's selecting next Davey satriano yeah that was
a pick I wish we would have had but we don't so
we move on so Cory you'll make our next uh pick
here yeah I'm going to go uh with a guy who's I
played against in the Metro division but Travis
KK I think he's been a a good offensive engine
for the Flyers surprising Flyers this year yeah
the Flyers are really surprising everyone right
now they're still very much in a playoff spot Bill
price the yellow team you guys are up next well we
said defense wins championships goal tending wins
championships in three on three Puck possession
wins and how do you get the puck possession you
win Faceoff so we are taking Vincent troch of the
New York Rangers i' like to put some respect on
face offs guys they're very very important blue
team finish us off in this round well we need a
goenda he hasn't been picked yet we're going to
take Jake ainger kind of surprised he fell this
slow but great pickup for you might be the steal
of the draft time for a little recap since we
added two more players to each of our rosters
starting out with the blue team they have William
neander Alias Pon Philip forsberg Clayton Keller
Kyle Connor and Jake ainger next up the yellow
team is on the board with Nathan McKinnon kale
MTH Sydney Crosby Mitch Marner eigor shester and
Rasmus darene and they added Carill the thrill
Capri of and Vincent tro the white team is up next
Conor McDavid and Leon dry side will lead the way
they added David Pastak thater Demco Sam Reinhardt
Matt Barelle Alex du Bret and Travis kkny and the
red team led by the Hughes Brothers we had Nikita
kucherov Brady kachak Connor huk JT Miller and
this round we had Sebastian AO and Brock besser
blue team you guys are once again back on the
clock just where we want to be and I just want
the world to know that we hold no grudges this guy
got us pretty good last year in the playoffs we're
going to take him and we're going to close out our
goal Sergey bosski of the Florida Panthers we know
what he can do against the best players in the
world which is us so he'll be even better against
the rest of these guys I like that description we
all know what he can do yellow team you guys
are up next did you guys take two goalies back
to back we did sure did wow okay goalie run I'm
going to throw this one up to Liam to make this
pick all right uh we are going to go with the
Canadian Canadian as he has not been taking yet
the center out of Montreal Nick Suzuki I like
that pick a very Canadian team over there with
those two Canadian guys white team your turn well
Cory I think knows this better than anyone when
you have two of the best skaters in the world on
your team you need some Jam so that they don't get
checked and messed around there in your All-Star
game so I think Tom Wilson is going to be a good
addition to our All-Star team here adding some
physicality I like it I like it now it's our turn
this time I let Pete go first Pete do you want to
take it away sure I love what Elias lyol has done
this season for the Flames through thick and thin
I also liked what he did a couple of seasons ago
when he had Matthew kachuck and Johnny gdo as
his Elite linemates so excited to see what he
could do with the allstar game baby I like lolm
I like it I'm surprised P Ela is this low I feel
like that's a sneaky pickup once again it's our
turn and I feel like now we got to take another
goalie right Pete and we're taking a look at a
Boston boy Jeremy San he's been killing it for
the Bruins this year they're not falling off
at a lot and it's all credit to the way he's
playing well we need a goalie too and uh sadly
that that Boston guy fell so Cory you can you
can select our last goalie here uh let's see here
I'm going to go with my C temporary in age cam
talot out of La okay we've shorted up our goal
the goalies are going quick they're going fast
yellow team you guys are up next on the clock 60
seconds well I've thought long and hard about this
one I loved this guy last year when he was on
the New York Rangers and he is probably one of
the most underrated players in the league having
one of the best seasoned in the league from the
Anaheim Ducks Frank vetrano he's light lamper left
right and Center seems like the mapa's voice has
something to say about that but you guys are up
on the clock with your next pick what do we think
got to huddle up here here little baby Yer maybe
you think so yeah is there a better one he's gone
well we're waiting let's do it go ahead well we're
going to go uh we're going to go west coast again
it's been popular for us uh we're going to go with
Tomas hurdle San Jose stole our pick so we're even
sorry Bill only one player left for each team so
let's recap these pass through rounds starting
off with the blue team they added Sergey bosski
and Tomas hurdle next up for the yellow team they
added Nick Suzuki and Frank vrono for the white
team they added Tom Wilson and goalie Cam talit
and the red team they added Alias lindhome and
Jeremy Swan blue team you guys are finishing
us off you're on the board before we make our
last pick we'd like to thank everybody in the
world we'd like to thank our celebrity Captain
Justin Bieber I think he's going to be proud of
our team when we're all done here to round out
our team we're going to add a sneaky good scorer
here in the last round Robert Thomas of the St
Louis Blues I like it it's crying that he lasted
this long your team is all wrapped up yellow team
I think I know who your final pick is but you can
tell us anything we would like to thank everyone
also including our celebrity Captain Tate McCrae
who will be playing the All-Star Game we're very
excited to see her show Liam take it away our last
pick all right our last pick we desperately need
a goalie uh so we are going to take Alexander gorv
out of Colorado desperately need a goalie or had
to add a goalie to your off and now we have three
avalanche on our team just like we planned it
a lot of former Rangers on there also kind of
scripted over there white team who is the last
player you're picking well uh Corey we uh we have
a choice here we can decide who Mr Irrelevant is
so uh you think we should go with Boon Jenner on
our team or Oliver borran I'll leave it up to
you our last forward pick our last pick uh you
know Boon Jenner's a captain and a veteran guy in
the league so I don't think I can leave him alone
to be the last pick so uh we're going to go with
Boon Jenner at a little bit to that sandpaper and
grit we got going on on team team white love team
a Powerhouse physically they are a Powerhouse now
raing it all up drum roll guys big surprise for
the last pick of this draft a guy Boon Jenner
loved playing with back in Columbus but now in
the Seattle Kraken Pete do you want to announce
the last pick yeah let's do it I also wanted
to thank our celebrity Captain Michael bé who I
heard through the gra Vine plays fantasy hockey
so represent we appreciate that support Pete
Pete's always pluging the fantasy content let's
do it so and he likes to be called hé now hug
yeah hé anyway Denmark's own Oliver Borg strand
h Shop volume Seattle Kraken are roaring into
the All-Star break so excited to have York Strand
on the club I like it guys we're all wrapped up
anyone have a steal of the draft that they have
on their mind so far I'm thinking about steel in
this jersey and not giving the fact I think the
steel was my partner here gu played with some of
these guys has all the knowledge but also we
did forget to thank our our celebrity Captain
Will Arnett hopefully we did him proud I we Cory's
got the jokes here so will probably was probably
going to like it when he sees this this team
also he's going to give you the uh the Batman
voice the Lego Batman voice we're very happy with
very happy with how it turned out here yeah guys I
don't think it's very fair that the white team had
Corey Schneider on this some Insider information
in their SEL C over there but overall this was
super fun I think we all have some stacked teams
we'll see how the real players select at NHL
Allstar Weekend February 1st through 3rd from
the great City of Toronto Ontario make sure to
tune in to all the festivities including the
draft once again on Thursday night thanks for
joining us here today on the NHL Allstar mock
draft
time to make my
team
another supp to be win it over he scores we on
a we are in a different Lane oh my God what a
stop mon scores connect me does
it again the scor let's go home
baby